>> Emily: BERNIE SANDERS GOING
ALL IN ON HIS CONTROVERSIAL PLAN
TO LET FELONS INCLUDING
TERRORISTS LIKE THE BOSTON
BOMBER VOTE FROM PRISON.
BERNIE TAKING IT EVEN FURTHER
WITH THESE COMPARISONS.
>> I SAID THAT BECAUSE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE IS ESSENTIAL.
IF YOU ARE A CITIZEN, YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THAT IS A RIGHT WE MUST PROTECT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT WOMEN DIDN'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
WE KNOW THAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> Emily: SANDERS IS ALSO
SLAMMING A FLORIDA BILL
REQUIRING FELONS TO PAY COURT
FEES BEFORE BECOMING ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE AS "RACIST AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL."
>> Dana: WE DID THE
FRUSTRATING THING YESTERDAY.
THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
WHILE BERNIE SANDERS IS TALKING
ABOUT IS PEOPLE IN PRISON BEING
ALLOWED TO VOTE.
THE THING IN FLORIDA IS NOT
GOOD.
IT'S A BILL THAT'S PASSED BY THE
HOUSE VERSION, STATE SENATE
VERSION IS DIFFERENT.
IT'S FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE GOTTEN
OUT OF PRISON WHO HAVE PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY.
THEY ARE OUT OF PRISON AND THEY
ARE TRYING TO PUT ADDITIONAL
CONSTRAINTS ON THEM.
THAT IS A SEPARATE TOPIC FROM
WHAT BERNIE SANDERS IS TALKING
ABOUT.
SORRY.
>> Juan: HERE'S MY POINT TO
YOU.
BERNIE SANDERS IS MOVING THIS
CONVERSATION INCREMENTALLY.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> Dana: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE A BACKSEAT
ON FALLON VOTING RIGHTS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
RESTORING FALLON VOTING RIGHTS
ONCE THEY GET OUT OF PRISON,
YES.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
BERNIE SANDERS IS TALKING ABOUT.
THAT WASN'T THE INITIAL THING
THE OTHER DAY.
AND HIM MOVING THE CONVERSATION
INCREMENTALLY IS TRY TO SAVE
FACE FROM HAPPENING THE OTHER
DAY BECAUSE THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS LIKE WHAT
DID HE SAY?
I WONDER WHAT JOE BIDEN WILL
SAY.
I BET HE WILL HAVE A BETTER
ANSWER.
>> Juan: I THINK HE MIGHT HAVE
A DIFFERENT ANSWER BUT IT'S A
CONVERSATION STARTER.
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT IT,
DANA.
>> Greg: WHEN DANA GETS THAT
MAD.
TAKE THE L.
>> Juan: EVERYONE IS TALKING
ABOUT IT.
TO SAY BERNIE, YOU'VE DONE
SOMETHING HERE BECAUSE LOTS OF
PEOPLE --
>> Jesse: LET'S GIVE BERNIE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
LET THE BOSTON BOMBER VOTE.
GOOD JOB, BERNIE.
>> Dana: THE MAYOR OF BOSTON
IS LIKE WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOU
ABOUT?
>> Juan: YOU ACT AS IF AMERICA
ISN'T HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
>> Greg: AMERICA --
THEY ARE NOT.
I GUARANTEE YOU THERE'S NO ONE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, THE BOSTON BOMBER
REALLY SHOULD VOTE IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
MAY BE RUN PRESIDENT.
HE COULD BE OF AGGRESSIVE
CANDIDATE.
>> Juan: YOU CAN MAKE A
CARICATURE.
>> Greg: I DON'T HAVE TO!
YOU ARE DOING IT.
>> Juan: IS AN APPOINTMENT
PART TO BE MADE ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP.
BERNIE, EARL WARREN, THE FORMER
CHIEF JUSTICE SAY YOU DON'T BE
CITIZENSHIP ON --
>> Greg: NOW YOU ARE ARGUING
THE POINT.
>> Juan: THE SAME POINT.
>> Jesse: LET'S ARGUE THE
POINT.
DO YOU THINK THE BOSTON BOMBER
SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE IN 2020?
>> Juan: DO I THINK?
I HAVEN'T CONSIDERED.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS SEGMENT FOR TWO DAYS.
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YES OR NO.
>> Juan: I THINK YOUR
CITIZENSHIP RIGHTS ARE NOT TO BE
REVOKED BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
ME.
>> Dana: WHAT IF YOU KILL ME?
>> Greg: AND THEY HAVE GUNS IN
PRISON TOO?
IT'S A SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT.
MAYBE HE COULD HAVE A GUN.
ALL INMATES HAVE GUNS.
GUTFELD 2020.
>> Juan: 22 STATES WILL
RESTORE A FELONS VOTING RIGHTS
AFTER, FOR A PERIOD AFTER.
YOU HAVE 14 STATES THAT SAY YOU
LOSE YOUR RIGHTS.
>> Emily: WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR THREE DAYS.
AS YOU KNOW, I SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WITH INMATES AND I
CORRESPOND WITH THEM.
I'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF EMAILS FROM
THEM IN THE LAST TWO DAYS.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY WATCH THEIR
SHOW.
>> Greg: DO THEY LIKE ANIMALS
ARE GREAT?
>> Dana: DO THEY LIKE CORNY
JOKES?
>> Greg: THEY SHOULDN'T BE
WATCHING "THE FIVE."
IT'S A RIGHT THAT SHOULD BE
DEPRIVED.
>> Dana: WE WANT THEM TO WATCH
"THE FIVE."
>> Greg: WE DON'T NEED THE
RATINGS.
WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Emily: THEY ARE PEOPLE TOO.
HERE'S THE POINT.
THERE'S THREE SECTIONS OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
THERE IS THE VIOLENT TERRORISTS
VOTING FROM PRISON.
THERE IS THE INCARCERATED
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS THAT REALLY
THIS CONVERSATION IS ABOUT.
AND POST-INCARCERATION, SUBJECT
TO FINES AND EVERYTHING WHICH IS
RIDICULOUS, SECONDARY
IMPRISONMENT.
MY POINT IS THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF SENTIMENT THAT IN THE
NONVIOLENT REALM, NOT EVERYONE
IN THERE IS THE GRIM REAPER.
>> Greg: WE KNOW.
YOU ARE ADDRESSING THE POINT
THAT BERNIE HAS SCREWED UP SO
BADLY.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE'S A
PERCEPTION OF THE LEFT THAT THEY
ARE SOFT ON CRIME.
THEY ARE ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT,
LET'S FACE IT.
ANTI-COPS, EVERYTHING.
NO ONE TAKES IT SERIOUSLY.
WHEN SOMEONE LIKE BERNIE SANDERS
SAYS THAT, IT FULFILLS THE
STEREOTYPE AND IT'S A TERRIBLE
THING TO RUN ON.
IF A REPUBLICAN CAME UP AND SAID
IT'S TIME FOR PRISON REFORM AND
I'M INTERESTED IN THOSE
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS HAVING THE
RIGHT TO VOTE.
EVERYONE GOES, IT'S A
REPUBLICAN.
NORMALLY THEY ARE STRONG ON
CRIME.
MAYBE I WILL LISTEN TO THEM.
IT'S A -- IT'S A PERCEPTION
ISSUE.
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE THING.
SENATORS HEITKAMP AND DONNELLY
WHO LOST IN THE MIDTERMS, THEY
ARE DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE STARTING
A NEW ENTITY TO TRY TO HELP
DEMOCRATS TALK TO PEOPLE IN
RURAL AMERICA.
GUESS WHAT.
HERE'S YOUR FIRST LESSON.
WHAT DID MAYOR PETE SAY WHEN HE
WAS ASKED ON THAT SAME NIGHT IN
THE CNN TOWN HALL, DO YOU THINK
FELONS SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE WHILE THEY ARE
INCARCERATED.
HE SAID NO.
THAT'S HOW YOU TALK TO PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
>> Jesse: IN INDIANA.
>> Greg: EVERYWHERE, FOR THAT
MATTER.
EXCEPT IN JAIL.
>> Emily: THESE GUYS ARE
COUNTED IN THE LEGISLATIVE
POPULATIONS.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE YOUR FREEDOM
TAKEN AWAY FROM YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE A NOT ALLOWED MOVEMENT.
YOU CANNOT LEAVE.
I DON'T SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SAYING THAT YOU ALSO
THEN CAN'T VOTE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE MY GUN
TOO.
I WANT MY VOTING RIGHTS IN MY
GUN RIGHTS.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Juan: YOU CAN'T HAVE AN
HONEST CONVERSATION --
>> Greg: YEAH, WE ARE ALL
LIARS.
>> Jesse: CHANGING THE
SUBJECT.
>> Greg: WE ARE NOT CHANGING
THE SUBJECT.
>> Juan: IT'S ABOUT GIVING
PRISONERS GUNS, YOU UNDERSTAND